okay welcome uh everyone to today's ddps
seminar um before we go into actual um
you know the fun part like the actual
presentations uh let me go over some
Logistics uh as usual um uh this um the
talk is going to be recorded and will be
available in YouTube channel and also um
it's um it's it's open to the external
audiences so uh no classifi discussion
um spee watch out for that uh and um
please mute yourself uh during the talk
um and if you have questions you can
unmute um and ask questions but if um or
you could you know leave your questions
in the chat chat room all right so
that's about it for the logistics and
let me introduce our speaker today I'm
I'm honored to um you know host
a um um the Y Jun Hong who is an
associate professor at sa National
University um and he focuses his
research on the mathematics of machine
learning and its application in
scientific Computing he earned his PhD
in mathematics with a minor in
scientific Computing from Indiana
University under the guidance of
Professor Roger ham uh where he
developed a strong Foundation
in theoretical analysis and
computational uh Technics during his
post work at the University of Illinois
at Chicago with Professor Jerry Bona and
David Nichols uh he conducted research
on electromagnetic and water waves
further horning his problemsolving
skills he later initiated independent
studies on the use of neuron networks uh
in scientific research leading to a a
focused research program at San Diego uh
State University where he began
investigating neural network
approximation within scientific machine
learning currently his work is dedicated
to developing theoretical Frameworks
that enhance the reliability and
applicability of neuron networks in
addressing complex scientific and
Engineering challenges
today uh uh Professor Hong y Jun is
going to um you know present us on his
work on operator networks based on the
numerical analysis I'm I'm sure he's
going to give a fantastic talk uh before
I pass the button to him let me ask it
well I'm sorry I'm lost
connection yeah no I think Yu lost the
connection
okay so I'm so sorry um yes I lost my
connection my computer just um shut down
on me all of a sudden I'm sorry about
that but I I was able to connect back
pretty quickly using my cell phone
technology um hopefully the the
recording is still going on um okay so
recording is still going on okay awesome
okay so I think I was about to ask a
questions right um y Jun so my question
is if you can um you know share your
story how you and ended up with uh on
this uh research uh field like the
scientific Computing and um the
computational science Etc um if you can
share some story especially for the for
the young um you know students um that
would be very
helpful um thanks um first of all thanks
for very nice introduction and it's my
honor to speak in the presenting the the
ddps seminar um so um the from The Young
s questions um so in fact when I start
my PhD I have no idea about the
scientific Computing and and of course
Moine learning this kind of thing
actually I want to study some
theoretical mathematics at the beginning
and um I um attend my advisor my former
advisor class which is um Navia St
equations and some kind of the the
numerical schemes and theoretical
numerical analysis and then I dive into
the the kind of the new research and
it's fascinating so I love it and I
thought that okay this is the the the
the area I want to study right now and
then I dive into this kind of area and
then it's very very um interesting to me
so in fact um there is no special region
to me there are no kind of special
moment to me but um I gradually like
this kind of the um the scientific
Computing and machine learning field in
them there are many um good
collaborators and Friends uh the in the
laboratory the the my advisor lab and um
I can interact with many of the my the
wonderful colleagues and the co-workers
at the
time and um yeah I think um that's the
reason because um the subject is it's
very interesting to me and um there are
many you know nice collaborators to work
with me so I think um you know that's
one of the reason and the other reason
ISM scientifically I want to study this
kind of the some some real world
application problem that's another
reason for me for the
moment I guess you're you know born to
be a um you know work in the scientific
machine
learning well thank you stage is
yours okay thanks um so um once again
thanks to the uh the thanks to uh
Professor uh Dr Tre and um the ddps
seminar organizers um so it's my honor
to speak here so I'm today I'm talking
about the operator networks based on the
numerical
analysis so um I think um everybody
knows what the scientific machine
learning right now so I don't need to
speak of this kind of the what is the
scien machine learning what it is what
it is but um yeah long story too short
it's like the machine learning plus
scientific Computing so we are going to
serve some um some scientific
engineering or mathematical physics
Problems by using datadriven or
sometimes some kind of the machine
learning techniques so it's kind of the
new are area and um each
multidisciplinary area so it's very
interesting to me for the moment okay um
although I'm talking about the AI today
I'm a mathematician so before I dive
into this kind of the machine learning
Fields I'm studying this kind of bound
the layer and singular pation in fluid
or circulation problem and sometimes
some nav to like equation I studied this
kind of the singular perturbation and
bound layer and sometimes inter layer
problems
and also I studied electromagnetic wave
numerically by using some kind of
spectral element methods and finite
element methods and I study this kind of
the basically I solve the max max
equation by using the some numerical
methods is period layered medium problem
so that's one of my subjects and um also
I studied um geophysical fluid dynamics
so this is some famous the Primitive
equations which is good for the
numerical R prediction and um I'm using
the finite volume method and then
solving the some kind of the this kind
of the rain shadow effects by using this
kind of um um excuse me this kind of the
Primitive equations but um right now my
interest is in the machine learning and
scientific Computing in the combination
of this in between them so I want to
make a bridge between scientific
Computing and machine learning and make
a a good development and good
Improvement for this kind of new Fields
New research Fields
so okay so the right now um The
scientifico Learning we have two kind of
the famous option one for the physics
informed option and the other one is
data driven options so many people knows
what the physics in neur networks and
demr methods so they are not using some
kind of the the data D methods but they
are you know successfully find them
solution for the given PD problems
and um another field is data deliver
method so it's soal the neuro operator
and they are they we have um two famous
new operator one is debonet the other
one is f neur operator and then they are
they are kind of the data driven
sometimes they don't use data but
normally they using the data driven
methods and then they can find um the
numerical
solution with a multiple instances so
there are two um kind of the big um two
area to to research Fields like the
physics informed and data
driven so um let's talk about just a
little bit more detail about the physics
INF neuron networks so this is um famous
fysic INF neural networks so we have um
the special coordinate and um temporal
coordinat tnx and then we can predict
the given solution and how can we train
this guy we can train this guy by using
the Reger information and um so this is
like the for instance we are going to
solve the burgo equation equation
initial condition and Boundary condition
these are all the regular information or
into the this kind of the Ross function
and then they can using the auto
gradient and auto differentiation by
using the py torch or tens of flow and
then they can find this kind of the the
derivative term and then they can
training this kind of the the burgus
equation solution so it's pretty much
well known and then it's very powerful
because um you know B col is mesh free
and we don't need to know the this kind
of the the data driven approach for that
so that's the physics in from your
networks and the other one is operator
learning so one of the you know drawback
for the physics inform neur networks
this is some they can only predict
single instances so if they want to find
another solution they changing the for
symptom initial condition they have to
train us again so to overcome this
drawback um the researchers find um this
kind of oper learning so they can handle
um the multiple instances but they need
some kind of the input out paired data
set for the training
process so basically the operator
networks they can learn this kind of the
mapping so input is for instance input
is like the initial condition and they
can predict they can find mapping for
this kind of the T is equal to5 T is
equal to 1 the given time the Sol
solution data a solution for the given
PDS so they just find they they just
basically learn the mapping from initial
condition to the specific solution
initial condition to specific solution
or sometimes they give a for syum and
then find the solution so they can do
multiple instances so they can change
initial condition they can change for
symptom then without further training
they can predict the numerical solution
so that's the operator like operator
learning operator networks and um you
know they can do the multiple instance
it's pretty much efficient in terms of
the engineering
perspective so and then this kind of
approach is pretty much natural in the
computer vision task because computer
vision they have some kind of input
image they can predict the output image
so it's kind of the the computer vision
is kind of the mapping process so they
can do for instance we have a this kind
the pon equation the input is this kind
of the for Sy M output is the given
solution so input that output pair and
then they can have this kind of the
neural networks they can learn this kind
of mapping so which is pretty much
natural in the sense of the computer
vision task but we are going to use this
kind of thing in in the the solving PD
problems so one of the you know Big
Branch is So-Cal the Deep onet so deep
onet they have a two different network
branch and TR trunk networks so I in my
understanding this trunk networks is
kind of the basis prediction and Branch
network is kind of the coefficient
predictions so they can have some kind
of the formation coefficient and basis
and then they can predict the good
approximation Solution that's my
interpretation and three neur networks
fno so which is also pretty much famous
and um so they have some kind of the
stack of the bchi on the data and then
they can influence the the next time
steps this kind of solution set so they
are smartly using this kind of the
convolution relation and then they're
using the inverse and forward fre
transform so input is is kind of the for
instance initial condition and for syum
and then using the encoder and then they
have a many fre layer in between and
output is decoder and this is solution
and this F layer consist of this kind of
the MLP layer and plus F and inverse for
for transform and then this R is kind of
the reduction so they can just um get
rid of the high frequency and then they
can just um you know handle the row
frequency to and then they can adding it
this is one fre layer and then they can
process this many the Manu fre layer and
then they can find them nice numerical
solution and this kind of the process
interpreted as this kind of the
convolution operation so it I think the
idea is very smart so I like this kind
of method but um I'm not going to talk
about today about this kind of the known
um the operator networks I'm going to
talk about the new operator networks
which is based on the numerical analysis
and numerical
method so what is the pros and cons of
the pins and operator networks I think
this is like the pretty much well known
part so pins are very easy to implement
and it's basically mes free so they can
handle various domain and equation and
it's basically unsupervised learning
some some people they say this is semi
supervised okay it depends on their
philosophy and they but but um the the
negative partage they can prict only one
single PD instance and then maybe it's
hard to impose the exact boundary
condition and operator Network they can
predict multiple instances so cor they
can solve the parametric PDS and um they
can use many you know new trend of the
computer vision architecture like
Transformer and unit this kind of the
architecture and um the one of the the
the the minus part it's supervised
learning so they need um pre-computed
input output data set by using the
numerical PD method and um sometimes
they have some kind of generalization
error the high generalization error kind
of
thing and um let's just this is like the
some one the limitation Advantage for
the scientific machine learning so the
limitation of the scientific Mach
learning is we don't have like some kind
of concrete error analysis and um
accuracy is not very high and um
training time is too long so it's kind
of the limitation but nevertheless we
need to study this kind of the scientif
mo running because the advantage is very
very you know interesting because they
can overcome Cur of dimensionality
because which simpling basis and they
can do the fast inference and they can
handle inverse problem very nicely and
potentially they can handle complex
problem and by using this kind of the
the machine learning the expressive
power they can handle this kind of the
complex problem so this these kind of
advantages are very fascinating to me so
that's why I'm studying this kind of
scientific machine learning right now
okay so this is um very quick
introduction so now I'm going to talk
about the operator networks with an aid
of the
numerics so um I think um everybody in
this room knows what the numerical
method for pte there are three famous U
find the the numerical PD method of
course there are May before to five
different methods but I'm going to talk
about the finite difference and finite
element and spectral methods of course
we need to study your finite volume
method boundary element method but you
know I think if you want to study more
then you can just um read the more
textbook and more papers but today I'm
going to more let focus on spectral
method and finite element method
basically finite element Spectra meth
Spectre element method they are rely on
this kind of the weak formulation and
they need this kind of basis fun
function finite element method basis
function is local basis spectral method
spect element method they are they are
using the global basis function which is
orthogonal
polinomial so and um like maybe over 50
years many of mathematician engineers
and physicist studied find element
spectral element find a different method
and there are many different branches
many different you know the the
methodology for solving the given
underly gbon in PD
problems so as I said finite element
method and finite Spectra element method
I'm going to talk about today so find
element which is good for the irregular
and structured mesh and then they need
use need to use a local basis function
and then accuracy is it depends on the
the the the order of the polinomial if
they're using the first order polinomial
the accuracy is not that high but um if
they using the high polinomial then
accuracy is very they have a very high
accuracy
and then competition cost is quite
moderate and in and then if you think
about the Spector element method they
are using the the global basis function
and um like the fander and chj
polinomial and they have a very high
accuracy using the very small number of
the polinomial they can use the high
accuracy numerical solution but
sometimes them computational cost is
very high and then they can handle just
um you know box like domain kind of the
problem in general of of course there
are many different method but normally
the global basis function is good for
the this kind of the you know box like
domain domain
problem
so motivated by the spectr method and
find element method okay let me start
from the Spectra method I'm going to um
explain the operator networks based on
this kind of spectr
method so this is the given um eliptic
problem I said this is 2D but not
necessarily 2D 1D 2D 3D 4D doesn't
matter so this is like the elliptic
problem and then we can find we
formulation from this kind of the
problem and this is given boundary
condition and then once we make this
kind of formulation we can use the the
gallar method we can find this kind of
the Sol solution
approximation and this VX VK this is
Basis function so if you want to go for
the Leander polinomial like this kind of
Leander polinomial then the basis
function consist of this kind of the
linear combination of three different
legendary polinomial and then this AK BK
can be determined by the given boundary
condition for instance if you have a
dular boundary condition AK 0 bk1 if you
want to have a homogeneous noral
boundary condition then this is zero and
this is like this kind of the
formulation and of course you can do the
loan boundary condition and you can find
AK and BK it depends on the your the
boundary condition
and um well this kind of the formulation
actually I just am talking about the ler
theander Spectrum method but if you want
to go for the CHF or Fu or the other
Bessel function or jaob polinomial then
you can use another polomia basically
the method is pretty much same and new
formulation is pretty much
same so what is my strategy so normally
when we think about the gallar method so
your solution ux then you can interpret
your Solution by using this kind of the
simple approximation and this VK is
known polinomial like Leandro CHF
whatever and this Alpha K which is
unknowns we are going to solve this
Alpha K by using the numerical method
like ax equal to B kind of the
method and um so my idea is okay so this
VK we all know this VK is good
polinomial because in numerics we
studied this kind of the basis function
for 50 years like the legand polomia and
CH polomia whatever this is we can know
this kind of the information of this VK
so my strategy is that what if we can
only predict this Alpha K by using the
neuron networks and then we can make
this kind of summation we I call this
one is reconstruction then we can find
this kind of accurate numerical Solution
by using this
approximation so our input is given F so
I just kn make this kind of the simple
random F so given F we can predict Alpha
K by using the neuronetrix and once we
predicts Alpha k then we can find this
kind of the by using this kind of the
Reconstruction we can find this un our
numerical solution that a simple idea
and
um how can we and then the problem is
how can we build our loss function to
train this kind of neuron network from F
to Alpha K given a to Alpha
K so the idea is we can make use of the
loss function the the we from loss loss
term so for instance very simple po
problem like minus Epsilon uxxx minus =
to F and then zero boundary condition
and we know how can we build this kind
of the the we formulation and then this
Fe FJR this kind of the the test
function and then by integration by
parts we can you know make this kind of
term by using the integration by parts
then this is left hand side minus right
hand side we want to make this is zero
if this is zero then our un is good un
and then you know this is our the L ter
and then the the question is how can we
pick up this kind of the FJ FJ is just
test function we have many options many
choices but if we want to go for the
this kind of the regender spectral
method then this VJ are our regender
basis function because of this un n can
be interpreted as um this kind of alpha
K and VK and this VK is same VJ like the
same luander polinomial then we can use
g r quadrature the numerical integration
is very high accuracy numerical
integration so we are going to use that
kind of the numerical analysis technique
and um well this kind of derivative also
exact because we know this form of the
FJ Leger polinomial we know how to how
to make a derivative for the even L
polinomial and also this un n it consist
of alpha K and VK summation we know what
the exact dity for this parts so you
know we don't need to take them any kind
of the numerical differentiation so we
can reduce the air once again so they
these are the architecture for the
legand gar neuron networks so our given
exter for symtom f and our neuron
networks whatever the neuron networks is
we can predict this coefficient Alpha K
and once we predict this coefficient
Alpha K we can reconstruct solution you
had and then once we can reconstruct
solution you had then we can make this
kind of loss function and then make once
we can make this loss
function then we can train this newal
networks and then you can you know go
and go and go and this process then you
can find accurate Alpha K as long as
this process is you know well setup well
defined so that's the basic IDE of
theander gar netrix idea is very
simple and um I tested this kind of the
1D 2D convection defin equation D
boundary condition and then hmer
equation with the nor homogeneous nor
boundary condition and also this burgus
equation the the zero boundary zero
boundary condition and burgus equation
is um not only a problem so normally in
numerics we need to think of iterative
method the Newton method
or fix to point method but um our idea
we just predict Alpha K that's it so we
don't need to do the iteration process
when we inflence the solution this
solution to the burgus equation so
that's another um good part of the this
kind of the spectr coefficient learning
the opport network
method so convection diffusion har
equation we can find accurate solution
so this is a zero boundary condition
case convection diffusion and this is um
the nor boundary condition case of the H
equation we can find quite accurate
solution in fact this simulation is done
maybe few years ago so right now we can
do the 10 toga five or six very high
accuracy numerical solution at the time
we didn't use um you know the the nice
the neuron netor architecture so I just
um showed the the only solution just um
it's very quite accurate in that sense
but right now we have a more accurate
Solution by using mized your networks
and um so this is a burger equation with
d boundary condition also nonlinear
Burger equation we have a quite accurate
solution and also I'm going to dive into
this kind of the bound layer problem but
you know boundary layer problem we can
also find very accurate solution so I'm
going to talk about this Bounder layer
later in detail and also 2D problem we
can actually get the 2D problem this is
um the our the predictive solution and
this is some exact solution we have um
relative Al 10 to4 each so which is
quite accurate so we can do those 2D
cases and um once we done this kind of
the alric type then we dive into the
parabolic type of the problem so time
dependent case so time dependent case we
have a U of T derivative so the main
question is how can we handle this the
time derivative so the one of the very
knif knif way but which is very power
way we can just using
the the oiler method implicit Oiler or L
kind of the numerical time derivative so
we can apply this kind of numerical time
derivative then this is kind of the UN +
one minus un over / th T then they can
become again one of the altic type of
the problem so we can iteratively
inflence this kind of the altic type of
the our the neuron networks then the
other process is pretty much same so we
can you know
the reduce our problem by using the the
time discretization by using the
classical numerical
method and also we can do the D no man
and periodic many different boundary
conditions and um the um basic idea is
pretty much same the only difference is
we have to handle this um the time
derivative Parts by using the classical
numerical um time discretization part so
that's basically our idea so each time
derivative part time discretization we
have a different neuron networks but um
we don't have like the 100 or thousand
of the neuron networks here we have only
10 neuron networks because um one time
set they can this neuron networks can
predict like the 10 step of the time and
this can this guy also can predict 10
step of the time so we can stack this
kind of thing and then make a one big b
formulation then we can training
everything and then this is kind of all
of the this process is like the
automization so you know everything is
automatic so we can influence very
quickly this kind of the whole the the
training the whole the inference
process so for the time dependent
problem we have um diffusion reaction
equation we have aatam and Visos burgus
and advection equation and convection
Division and gransy and na St equation
in 2D and um we have various different
boundary condition so sometimes we have
a zero boundary condition sometimes we
have um you know periodic boundary
condition and sometimes we have a noral
boundary condition but every different
boundary condition it works very well
because um in fact we have a this kind
of the approximation Alpha K plus VK the
basis function in fact the basis
function has information of the boundary
condition so that's why our boundary
error is zero it's exact so that's
another good part of our
method Okay so from the Visos burgus
equation we can predict pretty much well
so we compare our method with um two
different the unsupervised NE networks
Pino physics inform your operator and
python which is some Physics informed
doret so these are famous unsupervised
neural networks and then our SC L
spectral coefficient learning operat
networks this is some you know obviation
our method this some red one which is
the arrow is very low compared to the
other methods oh by the way I didn't
mention too much about this as you know
our L function we didn't use any
information of the input output pair so
our method is not data driven so our
method is unsupervised so we don't need
any kind of pre-computed data set so
that is another you know the important
part for the our method so that's why I
I compare our method with Pino and
python together and the the relative
error is much lower than the other two
um two methods and um diffusion reaction
ofaction we compare to the py the the
Python and the other method and you know
our method is like the low accuracy so
accuracy is very low so you know the
method is working very well and then in
this case of Direction equation we
cannot we don't have any kind of
reference the method so it only show our
the numerical the prediction so exact
and scon our method each well quite
accurate so error is like 10
to3 so time depend on problem it's also
working quite well and um we move into
the quite un complicated problem to the
graski and to the nav STS of course our
method well it's not super super great
but um it's like the 10 to negative 2ish
error like the 2% error but you know
it's working so that's another
you know the the 2D
example and um so that's like the eror
comparision table so our method onction
2dy we have um 1% error and um the other
method we compare with this one with
python and then well our our the
performance is better than python
physics in from dbet and then this
equation our AR is better than physics
in neur operator because our relative to
eror is more more or less 2% eror
so that's kind of the the numeric
accuracy for our the methods so again
our method is like unsupervised neuron
Network so we didn't compare our method
with the F and dbon
directly so after doing this process as
I mentioned this is BAS basically based
on the spectr element method but um
spectr element method which is not good
for the complex geometry like the
polygonal shape shape of the geometry so
I want to do the some kind of the
complicated geometry
like this circular or Circle the hole
with the square and polygon shape
sometime Dophin so this example came
from the Phoenix so so can we handle
this kind of a complex geometry with our
method the answer is yes the only
difference is we can change our bases
from the Leander polinomial to the
finite element polinomial like P1 P2
polinomial bases then we can do it so
the architecture is pretty much same the
difference is we can replace our polomia
from reandra to the P1 or P2 sometimes
P3 P4 then we can enjoy this kind of the
complex geometry by using the domain
triang
triangularization so the idea is pretty
much same so we have this kind of easy
toy problem like the reaction diffusion
equation then we can think of the weak
formulation so this is left hand side
and this is right hand side then we can
give our loss function by using the left
hand side minus right right hand side
regular form and then we can train once
again by using this reg Reger form then
that's it so that's the our defin
element operator
networks so again I showed the our
architecture so we have um our the given
for symtom input for symtom and then we
have a we can predict this kind of
coefficient by using the neuron netrix
and then this is P1 P2 element basis
whatever p P1 P2 each our choice if you
go to the P2 element then go for the P2
element then you can make this kind of
solution prediction and then make a loss
form and then train this your networks
and then going again again this kind of
the process like you know thousand if
pox then we can get the accurate
numerical Solution by using the operator
networks again this is unised Neuron
networks so we don't need any the
pre-computed data set and um this and
then the inference is we can do the
multiple instances so given input for Sy
term from sometime initial condition
sometimes boundary condition which are
input then they can predict with a
further training predict the numerical
Solution by using this kind of neuron
networks so for instance we we tested
this one is um I think that is the P
equation or convection defis one of the
equation this is a linear equation and
then the domain is kind of the square
with whole
polygonal shape of the domain and then
we our input is given F function forcing
function like this and this forcing
function oring function like this and
then I'm sorry they they just predict
our the the numerical solution very well
this is ground truth and this is ours
and that is debonet with only 30 the
data set input output pair so of course
Deon with 3,000 data set they can do
better but um hours are up the
unsupervised so we just test with a very
small data set if we have um zero data
set so I think that's kind of fair
comparision and um well ours are better
and also polygonal shape this is ground
and this is hours and this is Deon with
three 30 data sets so ours are also
quite
accurate and um this is some another the
interpretation so ground truth this is
our input and ground truth and this is
our which is good and this is Deon with
or the data set which is a little bit
you know a little bit difference between
here and there and this is physics in
debonet so and then this is another case
of the physics in debonet they can they
cannot capture the solution very well
but ours are keep capturing very well
look at this kind of the ground truth
and ours ours are find element Opera
networks so ours are
better and um we tested many different
domain domain one Circle domain two
scale with the hole domain three
polygonal shape and different boundary
condition homogeneous Recine homogeneous
Norman with this kind of equation and
also equation one and two which is some
general second order linear equation
equation two is burgus equation which is
n linear and then we tested it basically
everything is like the the percentage
error like the our errors are the
without know the training data set hours
are like the 1% and 0.5% 0.1%
0.3% quite accurate you know eror
prediction so compared to the physics in
from debonet and compared to the debonet
so of course we have a debonet with
3,000 supervised data set it's sometimes
it's good sometimes it's it's bad
because um you know we have a very
complex geometry but the ours are
concretely consistently have a good
prediction
and um the variable coefficient so we
have a input is a coefficient of the
given the given PD for instance we have
um CX is coefficient in front of the
convective ter for the convection defion
equation then they can
still predict the nice numerical
solution and also input as a initial
condition they can predict nice
numerical solution and um we can do the
a little more complicated problem like
the stocks equation in that case we
using the tailor Hood the p to P1 um the
fin element method they can predict
quite well and also we give a input the
boundary condition like this and this
part of the boundary condition then they
can also boundary condition as an input
they can predict very well so these are
the the comparision table so we compare
our method with the p debonet which is
an upgrade version of the debonet so
coefficient Deon ism thousand data a is
a little better but basically ours are
zero data set so ours are concretely
fine so and then we make this kind of
the the eror analysis so like the this
is what we do in the numerics so number
of element increasing how the look like
the the relative a error it decreasing
at number of elements decreasing and the
error also decreasing but this is a
little Dent so I'm going to talk about
this one quickly later so this is P1 and
this is P2 uh this is 1D and this is 2D
and the red one is P1 blue one is P2
element
method so okay I have only five or 10
minutes so so my method our method is
also good for the this kind of singular
perturbation problem so I think many of
you already knew what the singular
perturbation problem they can produce
bound layer or interior layer problem so
like this kind of the problem as Epsilon
decreasing and freezing then they can
produce very sharp transition near the
boundary or near the interior so it's
really hard to capture by using the CL
numerical method of course they can use
some ad meure refinement they can do
better but um CL numerical method is
really hard to capture and also in
machine learning which is very hard to
capture because um they are related to
the the spectral bias so spectral bias
they can learn the high frequency later
so it's this kind of the sharp
transition they can interpret it as a as
a high frequency high frequency so they
can learn this kind of the high
frequency very very slowly or sometimes
they cannot learn this kind of high
frequency so they are closely related to
this kind of the spectral bias so single
peration problem quite important when we
you when we handle scientif machine
learning problem so how can we handle
this kind of scien the singular
perturbation problem by using our method
so we go back to the our the singular
perturbation analysis PD and then we are
going to use this kind of PD idea into
our neuron networks that's our idea so
um okay I don't have enough time to skip
this kind of analysis apart quickly so
think about this kind of simple
convection deficient equation and zero
boundary condition problem and um from
here we can make um asymptotic analysis
so asymptotic analysis means that we can
capture only for the the sharp
transition Behavior nearby the
boundaries so this is like our astoic
equation so they are we call this one is
boundary layer solution so when we solve
this boundary layer solution then we can
capture this kind of sharp Tren profile
whatever this is 1D problem 2D problem
and um for this kind of the convection
diffusion type of the equation so
boundary layer profile is e to Theus X
over Epsilon that is called so-called
corrector function and in theoretical
pde by using this corrector function
they can solve this kind of Vanishing
viscosity limit problem
theoretically but in our method we are
going to capture only this um corrector
basis the corrector part and then make
it this one as our another enriched
basis function so this is like the P1
our finite element Clash car basis and
then we can add this corrector function
into our basis function and then we know
this character function by using the
singular perturbation analysis and then
this is called um enrich the basis
method so we can enrich our B our find
the element bases by using this
corrector function then this is our new
the finite element space and then we can
do the ging process by using this new
finite element bases then we can capture
the sharp transition so this is Epsilon
equal to one case so they have no
boundary layer for this equation so they
can do very well by using our the the
the fin element Ur netrix and this is
Epsilon 10 to5 they capture the this
kind of sharp transition because they
have a bound layer Epson th5 but we add
one more basis which is no further no
specific further cost one more basis
function and then they can capture this
kind of sharp transition very well this
blue one is exact solution this red one
is predicted Solution by using the our
the F element neuro operator the fail
net so adding this basis function we we
can capture this kind of sharp
transition so we can handle singular
operator Pion problem very well and um
time dependent problem I will show you
this kind of time dependent problem by
using the this video so this is like new
is 10 to 5ish and um our U zero initial
condition I I will show you the initial
condition
oops initial condition is very smooth
initial condition this new is small then
they can develop
this bound layer very
quickly but this blue one is um the
exact solution and red that is our
predictive Solution by using the our the
the finite element operator networks by
using the new basis function then they
can capture this sharp transition very
well so we can capture this kind of the
boundary layer phenomena quite well and
the interior layer layer case this is a
the
the FN and C C FN is like the triple AI
paper recently published 2024 they Ed
some kind of the similar idea by using
the the the the FN method and they have
a 900 training data set but our method
faet the finite element operator
networks without no data we have a 10 to
negative five accuracy or this kind of
the interlayer problem but you know the
other method there are good 10 to3 but
ours are little better but we have um no
training data they have a training data
so that's the difference so this is
inter inter layer cases and then we can
do the many different cases like the 2D
and circular and elliptical and this
kind of the polygonal shape we can you
know have a further extension and in
fact I didn't do this um polygonal shape
this is another example but I'm pretty
sure we can do this kind of the
polygonal shape by using the our the fet
with um special basis
function so three minutes I two minutes
I have so let me just talk about the
quickly the convergence analysis so our
approach actually based on the numerical
PD method so we
know so we try this kind of the the rate
of convergence kind of the analysis so
number of elements this is some relative
to error so in FM we know that P1 P2
elements we have um
or the rate of convergence negative -2
rate of convergence -3 so we
theoretically we can enjoy this kind of
the the conver nice convergence for the
P1 P2 the blue dotted dotted one but by
using the fin element operator networks
we decreasing this uh increasing the
number of
element then error going down and then
suddenly they are going up also arrow is
going down and then suddenly the arrow
is going up
so I thought that at the beginning oh
maybe this is problem for the neuron
networks optimization so maybe we can
make make use of the larger neural
networks then we can enjoy the better
convergence rate that's our the first
thought but actually it's not we changed
our neuron networks changed Optimizer
then this kind of the phenomena keep you
know appearing in our analysis so why
this happening why this what are these
hiccups so we dive into the the
the convergence analysis so our method
in fact our method is based on the
numerical pte so we can do the
convergence analysis by using the clal
numerical analysis so it's like the C
LMA bramber hbert and convergence
theorem which which is in the FM and
spectr element method we we know this
kind of the error analysis so we can
make use of this kind of similar an
error analysis for the scientif mo
learning so I'm not going to dive in
approximation generalization
optimization let me skip those parts so
in fact we make the our the error
estimate for our our fin element Ne
netrix then we have this kind of the the
eror bound so that means this what is
Capa a Capa a like the condition number
of our the the weak for Matrix so that
means this condition number actually
bothers our convergence so we have a
like the high condition number then our
numerical error relative error going
down so number of elements increasing we
know condition number is larger so
that's why they have this kind of the
hiccups like this and this kind of
hiccups and this red one is like the
theoretical Arrow Bound by using this
kind of the the our the the upper bound
so we can make use of this upper bound
and then we can just sketch it so it's
pretty much same so that is um
theoretically we can prove it so how can
we
handle this kind of the
hiccups of course we use more number of
the elements more more number of the
neurons then we can actually relax this
kind of the
hiccups and another idea so take n large
and large that's one idea another idea
we can use the preconditioning so once
we can use preconditioning we can just
handle this kind of the high condition
number then you
know with the prec conditioning we can
have a better numerical errors without
the preconditioning parts so that's one
of the idea so of course this is just
upper bound and we didn't take into
account the optimization error the
optimization error this is different
animal so we have to handle more
carefully so that's kind of the our the
you know ongoing research so we are
going to develop more and more this kind
of DM the anal analysis part by using
our the neuron
networks so okay let me skip this part
so we we I
also interested in this kind of the
foundation model for serving PD but I'm
not going to talk about this today so
let me introduce my collaborator
Professor Chango and ji and um namjun
Kim and these are my post Juno and Jin
they can help me to this kind of
simulation and Analysis all together so
we have a good team so we keep working
on this direction and um of course you
know this is not the best way to handle
um the PD problem by using the scien
motion learning so but you know we can
study more and more and then we just
feel that there are many more
interesting parts of this kind of scien
Mar learning for the
moment so that's the references so
thanks for the attention thank you thank
you thank you so much for the wonderful
talk um let's have a Q&A sessions if you
have questions on let me see the chat
room I don't see any question there so
if you have questions please unmute
yourself and ask questions while you're
thinking about the question I guess I I
can ask some questions so your your
method is unsupervised um method you
don't need data um so what what about
the the computation of cost like like is
it is faster than the um traditional you
know way of solving like the using the
finite method or on method um or is it
slower just like the penss physics
informs neur okay so
frankly so the in the for the training
it takes longer time than fvm and fvm of
course but um by doing inference we have
um much faster you know because um we
are inference is just one EUR networks
just um you know input and output
process so if you want to predict like
five ,000 you numerical solution very
quickly then I would recommend our
methods better but you know if you want
to find um 10 to -12 numerical solution
then maybe you have go for the spectral
method or discontin scharch method
that's better okay um so when you say
training is slower um um but once it is
trained you can inference but when you
when you do the inference can you like
inference on many different cases which
you haven't fainted on
yes okay so that that details I think I
have
to to yes so like um if you have a
different for symptom different initial
condition then they can predict very
fastly like the microsc they can predict
many things but um awesome yeah and um I
didn't spe spe speciically mention the
foundation model things but um my dream
is like the make a foundation model like
to make a different equation different
geometry and then predict everything at
once but once it is trained like once
training is done and
multitasking M multi problem yeah multi
physics yes but that's my dream so it's
quite farfetched right now but um you
know it's my first you know step oh
awesome okay I have another questions
one of the things for the singularity
uh the problems you know in order to
capture the that shop feature you have
to add like auxilary basis functions
what what kind of f basis functions did
you add so um okay that's very good
question thank thank you because I
didn't have enough time so I didn't
specifically introduce what the
corrector basis so um the In classical
numerics um I studied um the enriched
basis finite element spectr El method
sometimes find a volum method so I don't
want to use um adaptive measure
refinement because that's quite
expensive but I want to solve this kind
of the boundary layer interior problem
so in that case we can add one more
basis like the enriched basis and um
they can kep they are basically bound
layer interior Solution by using the
astoic analysis yeah so you can make
asmet analysis for the given PD You can
predict what you can you can actually
calculate what is the the boundary layer
solution like the inner solution the
inside the boundary layer and then
whatever this is 2D or 3D the solution
profile could be 1D profile because you
have a very nice boundary layer so of
course if your geometry is very much
ugly then maybe the bound your corrector
the basis function is also ugly but
maybe if you have some nice kind of the
domain trade then you can find this kind
of good the
the the um the corrector function then
you can add this correct function to the
your the fin element basis that is
called the enrich fin element method so
I just make use of this new basis
function into our the the finite element
operate Matrix okay it's basically pde
kind of the oriented idea okay awesome
okay
so do you have questions yes yes please
can you use the idea to other uh one uh
uh that kind difference Fin volums and
the mist or boundary those kind
ofco
B yeah that's very good question I I'm
actually thinking that um how can we um
make use of this idea into Define a
volume method but um um one thing
bothers is that um we I have to compute
blocks and um it's like so it's it's not
very very easy to think about how can we
just the fluxes and then for the
different geometries so it's not very
straightforward but um I'm also thinking
about how can we apply this idea to the
finite volume method and um you know I'm
kind of big fan of the finite volume
method so because they have conservative
structure so I love that but yeah I'm
still thinking
about yeah I think that's great idea
because combine the crash Computing
method with AI the new methods so all
and new coming together I think as you
demonstrated your talk is excellent
wonderful
congratulations thank you thank you so
much thank
you we we have another question from um
Kevin uh he he's asking does the neural
network outputs all coefficient values
of the basis functions or are there
multiple neural networks each outputting
one coefficient value oh it's like the
neur one neural networks output to all
coefficient values of the bases so your
output could be Vector of the B the the
coefficients okay and the the dimension
of the output could is like number of
coefficients you have in yes exactly
yeah okay uh sounds good is there any
other
questions if not let's think how our
speaker um y y Jun for the nice talk and
hopefully um after this presentations a
lot of people is going to reach out to
you and then um you know ask questions
and also you know establish a future
collaborations um thank you so much yeah
okay awesome well with that let's uh end
our uh ddps seminar today let me stop
the stop record button